hello everyone and welcome to a big
matchup from round three it is candidate
Gish versus world champion ding Len and
I mentioned yesterday after his win
against we gkes will face dingering with
the white pieces and this is as great an
opportunity as you can hope for uh so
let's see what happened here it's quite
a game a lot of lines will be explored
hope you guys enjoy it uh let's check it
out so GES with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to E4 and ding replies with
Pawn to E5 we have Knight to f three
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to C4 going
for the Italian game uh Knight to F6 the
two knights defense and now Pawn to D3
the so-called modern Bishop's opening uh
we have Bishop to C5 and now Pawn to C3
transposing into the main line of the
Joko piano we have Pawn to D6 and now
Pawn to A4 uh now this is the Joo panimo
we have Pawn to A5 and now Bishop to G5
so all been play before nothing new here
I'm pretty sure both Gish and ding have
played thousand of games in this exact
particular setup we have Pawn to H6
Bishop to H4 and now Bishop back to A7
and uh here although the position is
still know one Knight B to D2 is the
move that was played and it was played
in the game prag versus tabatabai uh in
the Asian uh games for men in
2023 that pran on the one but here gkes
deviates from night2 he plays Knight to
A3 and it is now already as of move nine
that we have a completely new game and
in the in the Joo piano against the
world champion this is uh well we we can
consider this quite an early deviation H
and okay ding has to now continue Queen
to E7 he's hinting that he might also be
interested in maybe castling Queen side
uh we have Knight to B5 uh now going
after the bishop on A7 and the bishop to
B6 D ding wants to preserve his Bishop
uh Queen to
B3 very strong move here because um well
you are putting pressure on that F7 pawn
and also uh maybe if the queen moves
there are some tactics with Knight
captures and D6 Pawn captures then Queen
captures and B6 all in all a very
tactical position we have Pawn to G5 of
course this always gets played Bishop to
G3 and ding says I'm castling King side
here uh and gcash went into a 20 minute
thing here so it's the first real think
of the game and he decided to Castle
Queen side and okay Knight to H5 putting
pressure on the bishop but also maybe
hinting at Knight to F4 uh also maybe in
the future some King G7 maybe F5 can be
played not for the moment as the
diagonal is occupied by the queen and
the bishop uh but by playing Knight to
H5 uh the E4 Pawn is no longer watched
by the Knight so the gash takes this
opportunity to advance the pawn to D4 uh
e captures on D4 by Ding and now how do
you recapture well you could capture
with either Knight or you could play
with C captur on D4 and C captur on D4
is an incredibly complicated line that I
am more than happy to show you if C
captures on D4 uh then uh the best move
is Queen captures on e4 of course Knight
captures on D6 now attacking the queen
and after C captures you play Bishop
captures and D6 so you take two pawns
for the piece also you're attacking the
rook and also you're threatening to win
your piece back but here comes Knight to
B4 now uh just offering The Rook here
first Rook H to E1 uh getting the Rook
into the game for free Queen back to C6
and now you're going to take the Rook
here for example captures captures and
Knight to E5 you attack the queen with a
triple attack on the F7 pawn queen to C7
defending and now Queen to F3 Shifting
the queen back here at to F3 to uh put
more pressure on F7 but also to attack
the Knight on H5 and after Knight to F4
is played this is where it really gets
in interesting up up until this point
I'm pretty sure both of them calculated
this instantly but here G3 cannot be
played uh the point is okay now if the
bishop if the Knight moves it's going to
be big trouble but there's Bishop to E6
eliminating one of the attackers of the
F7 pawn and now after B3 because you
really have nothing better than Bishop
to D5 kicks away the queen and black
just retains a better position so you
you can play Pawn to G3 what you can
play is Pawn to D5 uh very weird but
also very strong and now after Knight
captures on D5 you will play Rook
captures on D5 and after Knight captures
Queen captures again with a triple
attack on F7 there's Bishop to E6 and
that's how you solve all of your
problems Queen will move to E4 but now
you just trade Bishop captures Knight
captures and Bishop captures on F2 and
black is just better he's up a pawn but
that's all all all black needs uh you
can't really go after some Queen H7 as
the Knight here would hang with check so
it's just uh better for black so that's
why not see captur on D4 instead Knight
B captures and D4 was played also you
could capture with this Pawn uh sorry
with this Knight Knight which means that
now if G4 is played this Knight cannot
occupy the D4 square but it seems that
gkes did not want this Knight to occupy
the D4 Square H because after G4 he went
Knight to H4 what you can do is also
just take on
C6 and after the trade happens just
bring this Knight to D4 uh also works
very nicely but after G4 Knight to H4
was played now also looking at Knight F5
and also Knight to G6 since the F7 Pawn
cannot move uh Bishop captures on D4 by
D C captures and now Queen captures on
e4 just boldly grabbing that E4 Pawn
Rook H to E1 and only one square for the
black queen and that is the H7 Square
ding Retreats with Queen to H7 and now
comes Rook to D2 and here uh I I will
just show you a line that is objectively
best and then we're going to see what
Gish played uh because Gish line is
incredibly interesting so best here is
just Bishop D3 you go after the queen so
Queen has to go to G7 and now you play
Knight to G6 again the DF Pawn cannot
move you're going to see Knight captures
on D4 attacking the queen here Queen to
D5 and now Knight captures on G3 Knight
captures on f8 King captures on f8 H
captures on G3 and now a couple of um
options that black has you can go Knight
C6 Knight E6 you can also deliver a
check here go for a queen trade for
example captur captures uh and it's um
uh well white is up the exchange but
Black's position is just incredibly
solid so it would be nothing more than a
draw here let's say Knight B3 check King
to B1 Knight to C5 and just very very
strong for black black is up two pawns
uh not much to worry about here so uh
this is what's possible and Bishop to D3
is objectively best in this position
however Gish played Rook to D2 and it's
a very tricky move as you'll see in the
game uh so what can ding do now well
obviously he can't move the bishop that
would hang the B7 Pawn so that's exactly
what he does he plays Bishop to D7 and
now uh you can't really capture on B7 if
you capture on B7 then Knight to B4 and
look at this beautiful queen here
controlling this diagonal Knight to A2
uh check also if the bishop moves uh it
would be it would be too much and if you
trade Queens here for example captures
captures then D5 comes attacking the the
the bishop and the rook and even if you
attack the bishop here on E7 then Bishop
captures on A4 will happen you grab a
pawn and black is just better the
bishop's still hanging you have to move
it and after Knight captures and G3 H
captures and Rook f d8 um you know
you're up a pawn you have better
position it's a good life for black so
instead after this bishop to D7 move
gukas went Bishop to D3 now but now it's
a little bit different it's not as
potent as in the line that we've just
discussed because now after uh Queen to
G7 there's no Knight to G6 if Knight to
G6 now you can just play Rook f8 uh
which was not a possibility when the
bishop wasn't on C8 disconnecting the
Rooks here the bishop is on D7 and the
Rooks are nicely connected so here
instead Bishop to F5 is played uh and
now Bishop captures on F5 Knight
captures attacking ding's Queen and
queen to G5 also a nice thing about this
Rook to d2 move is that Queen to G5 does
not come with check and here uh what do
you play uh again if you capture on uh
on B7 and sort of give up D F5 Knight
for the C6 Knight it's nothing uh
nothing spect tler Rook eight to B8 and
it's still black who better uh you
cannot capture on C7 of course the other
Rook just comes into the game and the
point is that the the Knight will always
be better than the bishop here and you
you can easily double Rooks on the B
file so you know Black's position is to
be preferred objectively could still be
a draw uh but black is better here
however gkes went for Queen to B5 and
now we have Rook F to E8 and Rook to E3
so here with a trade it's still possible
to play but after Rook to E3 uh ding
just completely takes control of the
game and he does so by playing Knight to
G7 and it doesn't look like a move that
should uh do all that much but the
problem is and uh you'll see how how
problematic this is Knight captures King
captures uh you cannot trade Queens if
you trade Queens here for example
captures captures uh what do you play
here uh there's just no good
continuation here if you trade Rooks
then you just give black theile for free
if you play something like uh Rook to C2
you want to get the Rook um up the board
to help out with the fourth rank uh Rook
e to C8 now also now the Knight can move
as the C7 Pawn will not be a problem and
if Rook to C4 you will play Pawn to F5
threatening Pawn to F4 so you're going
to have to play Pawn to F4 here G
captures Rook captures King to G6 and
again you have this problem that the
Knight will just be better than this
bishop here so uh it would be a slow and
painful death against someone like Ding
and so here Gish played Pawn to D5 but
now ding plays Rook captures on E3 F
captures on E3 and now feel free to
pause the video and try to find uh the
only winning move for ding while I give
you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
touching the pawn and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Knight to B4 Knight to B4 is such a
devastating move as it gains control
over all of these beautiful squares and
ding hints that he's not interested in
material he wants to grab hold of this
diagonal and go after the white king uh
notice that there's no light Square
Bishop anymore guarding that A2 Square
so we imagine a king a queen on F5 and a
knight on A2 that will be Checkmate so
how can Lukes play this he plays Queen
captur on B7 attacks The Rook but just
Rook to E8 ding brings The Rook into the
game and now your last chance is to
trade Queens with Queen to A7 but by
last chance I mean your chance of maybe
prolonging the game that you will still
lose uh and it's not going to be very
nice for example captures captures
captures and now after let's say Rook to
D4 going after the pawn you're just
going to play F5 and black Black's
position is just um completely winning
there there's not even a good move for
white here uh so instead Gish played
Pawn to F4 attack Bishop to F4 attacks
the queen also guards the E3 Pawn but
now just Queen to F5 threatening Knight
to A2 Checkmate so how do you stop this
well Queen to B5 well it's not Checkmate
yet as you can move to to D1 uh but the
king Hunt is now on Knight to A2 check
King to D1 Queen to B1 with check King
to E2 and now Queen to G1 going after
the pawn here uh so uh King to D3 The
Rook now defends the pawn but now again
the Knight retreats to B4 with check and
you've seen how in all of the line in
all of the hypothetical lines that we've
explored Knight to B4 was just a deadly
deadly move move and even in the final
line that that sort of takes Gish down
uh Knight to B4 is the is the move so
here if you play King to C3 then just
Queen to C1 check picks up the Rook also
this is impossible uh and after Knight
to B4 check King to D4 was played but
now just Queen to E1 trapping The Rook
here uh so what can you do if if you
play Rook to E2 okay the queen still
defend but just Queen D1 check there's
no
uh no more good moves and after King to
C three Knight to A2 check King to C4
Rook to E4 will be Checkmate so even
that so Rook to D3 was played trying to
give up The Rook here but of course ding
not interested in that he's going for
checkmate Queen to E2 uh we have Rook to
C3 now and here comes Queen to D2 with
check King to C4 we have Rook to E4 with
check and he was in this position un
move 37 dead gkes resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
whatever you do you're getting
checkmated here only move is King to be
three but then comes Queen to D1 with
check King to A3 and now Queen to A1
check King to B3 Queen to A2 and this
will be Checkmate or any of the other
lines that you might choose for the
black king they all end in Checkmate
yeah very nicely done by ding so it was
um uh gash tried to tried to you know
find the weakness in ding's armor tried
to go for not the absolute top move
recommended by the engine but sometimes
that second move recommended by the
engine hoping that maybe D doesn't have
it in his preparation uh but the ding
just played extremely fast uh pretty
much the entire game uh we can even
check the yeah in the final position
after this uh landed here yeah nothing I
mean ding had ding had an 52 minutes
almost an hour on the clock and GES was
uh below the 10 minute Mark so yeah very
strong performance by Ding and good try
by GES but uh yeah ding takes this one
with the black pieces uh so so what are
you going to do first win for for the
world champion very nicely done uh we'll
see what happens in the next round and I
will now mention some of the results if
there are any I don't know as I'm
recording while it's being played a
couple of games have uh finished uh Jun
lost to Jan F Forest Alexander donchenko
seems to be in a losing position against
Anish giri uh vidit still seems to be in
a drawn position against nepo Max vam
Drew against ala prananda against Wei
appears to be a draw but still being
played and um Abdus satro defeated
makulu so a lot of action happening uh
if you guys have any favorites do use
hashtag suggestion and I will gladly go
over them uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it nicely done by
the world champion with the black pieces
against an incredibly strong player
guesh uh also one of the candidates of
the 2024 candidates tournament so he got
uh he got a little a taste of what it
will feel like to play against ding Lan
if he actually wins the candidates
tournament uh so he knows that he will
have to improve uh you know in a lot of
in a lot of sense uh so once again
really hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank Welsh fan Mark Henley Brennan
hen Frank Banner best content maker and
Brian pwin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day